This is Christian veiling.
At the first glance,
you might have thought that that was a hijab
or a Muslim head covering.
I've been noticing how many Christian women
are coming out unveiling nowadays.
But what's the purpose of veiling?
Let's look at the Bible.
Veiling is actually not a new thing.
It's been a tradition for many years.
Ever since Christianity first started.
We see Mother Mary wearing a veil in all her pictures.
In Corinthians 11:16.
In the Bible,
it states that if a woman is not covering her head,
she might as well just chop her hair off.
But the concept of veiling mainly applies to
when a woman is praising god in the church.
But now women are so brave to wear their
wearing a veil in public as well.
Not only in the church.
Mother Mary was prime example
of holiness and purity in a woman.
And now many women nowadays
are following in her footsteps.
Veiling is true representation of humbleness before god.
It's a woman's way to honor god
with the beauty that he gave her.